♪
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, EARLIER
THIS WEEK THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION SUED THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR ITS
FAILURE TO COMPLY WITH
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION LAW.
SO WE SENT OUR OWN TOMI
LAHREN OUT TO LOS ANGELES TO
FIND OUT WHAT CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS THINK.
THIS OUGHT TO BE
INTERESTING.
TAKE A LOOK.
♪
>> DO YOU THINK THAT WE HAVE
AN ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA?
YOU'RE SMILING.
YOU DON'T WANT TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION?
>> YEAH.
>> OH, BOY, HOW LONG DO WE
HAVE TO UNPACK.
[LAUGHTER]
>> ARE YOU AWARE YOU ARE IN
SANCTUARY STATE.
>> NO, I'M NOT.
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME
KNOW.
WHAT EXACTLY DOES THAT MEAN?
>> THAT MEANS SANCTUARY FOR
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
>> I THINK THIS IS A SAFE
PLACE FOR A LOT OF RESIDENTS
TO CONTINUE LIVING AND I'M
PROUD OF THAT.
>> IF YOU ARE AN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT YOU CAN BE
HARBORED, SHIELDED UNTIL
YESTERDAY BECAUSE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL SAID NO
MORE OF THAT CALIFORNIA.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL, I MEAN, IF THAT'S
THE WAY THAT THEY ARE DOING
IT, THEN WE SHOULD EMBRACE
IT.
>> THE GOVERNOR HERE IS A
CRIMINAL.
THAT'S A CRIMINAL ACT.
YOU'RE GOING AGAINST THE
LAW.
>> I THINK IT'S GREAT.
I THINK AMERICAN IS FINE ON
IMMIGRANTS AND IT SHOULD BE
THAT WAY.
>> PAY TAXES AND WORK.
AMERICAN DREAM FOR
THEMSELVES.
THEY SHOULDN'T BE SHELTERED.
>> I THINK FOR ME IT'S ABOUT
THE RULE OF LAW AND NEEDS TO
BE RESPECTED.
YOU WANT TO COME IN THIS
COUNTRY, COME IN THE RIGHT
WAY, RESPECT OUR LAWS,
RESPECT OUR CULTURE AND THEN
I THINK WE WELCOME EVERYONE.
I THINK THERE IS A RIGHT AND
WRONG WAY TO DO IT.
>> I WOULD AGREE.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT IT
WOULD BE EASIER IF WE DIDN'T
HAVE SO MANY ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS ALREADY?
DO YOU THINK THAT LEGAL
IMMIGRANTS COULD GET IN
EASIER?
>> I DON'T KNOW, LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA LIKE ALL OF OUR
FRUIT IS PICKED BY
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS.
I WANT TO KEEP EELGT
AVOCADOS.
DO YOU LIKE GUACAMOLE.
>> ILLEGAL.
IT'S NOT WHAT THIS COUNTRY
STANDS FOR.
THERE HAVE A LOT OF RULES
THAT AREN'T EASY TO NAVIGATE
WE MIGHT AS WELL NOT TRY TO
PUNISH PEOPLE BECAUSE OUR
SYSTEM IS SO DIFFICULT.
>> THE HAPPY MEDIUM WOULD BE
LET PEOPLE COME IN BUT DO IT
THE RIGHT WAY.
>> YES.
THERE YOU GO.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
WALL.
>> WALL A WASTE OF MONEY.
WALL WOULD HAVE TO FIND A
NEW WAY TO GO OVER.
>> I DON'T BELIEVE A FENCE
IS THE ANSWER.
HONESTLY I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE ANSWER IS.
>> WE GOT A BIG BEAUTIFUL
WALL WITH A DOOR.
WOULD YOU LIKE THAT WALL?
>> PROBABLY NOT.
>> YOU WOULDN'T LIKE THAT
WALL AT ALL.
>> NO.
>>
WOULD YOU VISIT THE
WALL?
>> NO.
>> OKAY.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
JOINING US WITH MORE IS FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR TOMI LAHREN
AND CATALINA MAGAZINE
PUBLISHER KAT AREU.
DO YOU BELIEVE IN THE RULE
OF LAW?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Sean: OKAY.
IS IT ILLEGAL TO ENTER THIS
COUNTRY I ASKED YOU THE LAST
TIME.
>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: WITHOUT PERMS IN
THIS COUNTRY IT'S ILLEGAL,
RIGHT?
IT'S ILLEGAL.
DON'T MAKE ME DO THIS AGAIN.
>> AS I SAID I THINK MANY
PEOPLE ENTERED LEGALLY AND,
GIVEN THE CIRCUMSTANCES
PERHAPS STAYED FOR OTHER
REASONS.
>> Sean: ARE THERE PEOPLE
WHO BROKE OUR LAWS AND DON'T
RESPECT AMERICAN LAW?
THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO
GET OUT OF YOU.
IT'S A SIMPLE QUESTION.
>> IT COMES TO A WORLD
SHOULD WE REALLY HAVE
BORDERS?
ISN'T THIS ONE WORLD?
ONE PLANET?
SHOULD WE GO BACK TO JOHN
LENNON AND NOT WORRY ABOUT
COUNTRIES AND BORDERS AND
KEEPING PEOPLE OUT?
>> Sean: I WENT DOWN TO
TEXAS, 642,000 TEXANS WERE
VICTIMS OF CRIME BY ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS SEVEN YEAR
PERIOD.
DO YOU EVEN CARE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Sean: DO YOU CARE ABOUT
THOSE TEXANS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Sean: DO YOU CARE ABOUT
KATE STEINLE'S FAMILY?
DO YOU CARE ABOUT KATE
STEINLE'S FAMILY?
>> OF COURSE.
AND I CARE ABOUT ALL THE
FAMILIES OF THE KIDS WHO
HAVE DIED IN SCHOOLS BECAUSE
OF OUR HOMEGROWN CRIMINALS.
THESE ARE HOMEGROWN.
>> Sean: RUN ON SENTENCE
THAT SAYS NOTHING.
>> WHY?
HOMEGROWN CRIMINALS ARE JUST
AS BAD.
I HAVE A QUESTION OF MY OWN.
DO YOU LOCK YOUR DOORS AT
HOME AT YOUR RESIDENCE?
DO YOU HAVE A LOCK ON YOUR
DOOR?
DO YOU USE THAT LOCK.
>> I DO, YES.
I DO.
>> Sean: DO YOU HAVE AN
ALARM.
>> I DON'T.
>> WHY IS THAT?
YOU LOCK YOUR DOOR BECAUSE
YOU WANT TO KNOW WHO IS
COMING INTO YOUR HOME.
IT'S NOT BECAUSE YOU HATE
THE PEOPLE OUTSIDE.
IT'S BECAUSE YOU LOVE THE
PEOPLE INSIDE.
WELL, THAT'S WHAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE WITH THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE A BORDER.
WE HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW WHO
IS COMING INTO OUR COUNTRY
AND WHY.
THAT'S WHAT KEEPS US SAFE.
THAT IS WHY SEAN AND I CARE
SO MUCH ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
>> IF I HAD LAW ENFORCEMENT
IN MY HOME AND PEOPLE TAKING
CARE OF ME I KNOW SOMETHING
WENT WRONG SOMETHING IN MY
HOME THEY WOULD TAKE CARE OF
IT I DON'T HAVE A POLICE
OFFICER SLEEPING OVER AT
NIGHT SO THEREFORE I LOCK MY
DOORS.
SO, IN OUR COUNTRY WE DO
HAVE SYSTEMS IN PLACE THAT
PEOPLE COMMIT CRIMES, THEN
THEY WILL BE PUNISHED.
>> WE HAVE SYSTEMS IN PLACE,
THAT'S RIGHT, CALLED THE
LAW.
THAT'S THE WHOLE ISSUE HERE.
IT'S CALLED THE LAW.
YOU HAVE NEED TO RESPECT
LAW.
>> AND THEY DO.
MILLION OF IMMIGRANTS DO
RESPECT THE LAW.
>> WE DON'T HEAR ABOUT
MILLIONS OF IMMIGRANTS